from a lot of fans of mine as well
how could I be anti-porn when I used to
run a webcam Studio well
I'm sure most of you know the answer to
that question
most of you know the answer to the
question is because people change
my brother is a Muslim my brother would
never ever ever have me running a webcam
studio in his house or near him ever
again
and I don't blame him and you say oh Can
people really change that much well why
don't you do a little bit bit of
historical research
and tell me who was Malcolm X
before he converted to Islam and found
God who was he what did he do
I'm reading the chat does anyone know
correct well done one person got it
right Malcolm X was a pimp
congratulations Fraser you are correct
he was a pimp and a street Hustler now
if you're talking about running a webcam
Studio completely legal tax paying
business there's work contracts there
are hundreds of webcam Studios all over
Bucharest very popular business in East